würde dir 1000 euro erweisen wenn du mir
deine telefonnummer gibt wirklich keinen
spaß kann auch erst überweisen
1000 euro
[Musik]
ein motto ausgedacht und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja
leute ich hoffe natürlich euch geht's
gut ich hoffe natürlich ist auch gut
leute heute mit einem video das ich nie
gemacht habe
ihr seid ja von mir jetzt in letzter
zeit mehr so produktvideos gewohnt ich
habe jetzt aber gedacht kommen wir
machen mal so ein video wie es auch von
einem jahr gemacht hätte und zwar ist
uns das gestern aufgefallen marie hat
wieder irgendwie so eine dumme instagram
die em bekommen
und irgendwie hab ich auch das gefühl du
kriegst deutlich mehr instagram
nachrichten als ich also ich bin jetzt
nicht so der klebstoff instagram habe
bei ihr sind auf jeden fall viel mehr
lustige dabei das liegt natürlich auch
daran weil ja wenn er dich eher
anschreiben als frage mich so weil es
ist ja irgendwie so und wir haben uns
gedacht
da wäre man blick rein analysieren die
so ein bisschen und schauen was sie da
geschrieben wurde
im insgesamt zehn stücke ausgesucht die
zeigen wir euch mal und wir werden
fertig ganz viel spaß
ok ich würde sagen wir lesen sie mal
abwechselnd vor also ich fange jetzt
folgen wird er erst sondern sagt jedoch
aus dazu okay
und zwar hat philipp geschrieben er war
eigentlich echt interessante fragen
beantworten kann ich das eigentlich wird
halo marie kannst du mir mal sagen wieso
mädchen so gerne lange nägel haben ich
mag es zwar aber warum
also ich fand es eigentlich das
interessant weil ich kann gar nicht
beantworten die frage man längst nicht
so lang wie vielleicht bei vielen
anderen mädchen aber auch nicht so kurz
wie bei vielen anderen mädchen kann ich
war jetzt schon mal philipp jetzt mal
logisch nachgedacht du sagst hallo marie
kann man sagen wieso mädchen so gerne
lange nägel haben also philipp fragt
warum das so ist philipp sagte danach
ich mag ist zwar weist das ist doch
jetzt schon eigentlich um direkte
antwort auf die frage mädchen naja weil
er jüngst denke machen nur alles für die
mädchen die jetzt aber es stimmt
überhaupt nicht gemacht
naja also so ein großteil natürlich
schon also natürlich natürlich macht man
das auch um fremde person zu imponieren
sowas steht dafür für schönheit soll ich
mal und deswegen gehen mädels zwei oder
drei mal pro monat ins nagelstudio stick
kann dann einmal muss also philipp ich
habe deine frage ist hier wird von mir
beantwortet aber meist als ich meistens
mädchen die schwanken noch immer so
zwischen langen kurzen also ich habe zb
jetzt auch nicht mehr lust auf lange ich
lasse mir demnächst wieder ganz nah bei
uns ist das so man kann hier einfach man
muss gar nicht ins tagesschau.de wenn
man halt wieder die nägel kürze bilder
machen wir auch so
du bist da sind vorlesen anhand von
makro have to say we sing und heute noch
rein geschrieben hast du hast so
handlich geantwortet nein warum ich ist
doch sympathisch ja überhaupt vor allem
an das geschriebene an den ok doch passt
und vor allem hang hat am 19
und wenn man schon mal geschrieben und
der ist dann zwei monate später ist hat
er immer wahrscheinlich jeden tag guckt
achim ihr geantwortet
und dann hat er am neunten jahr doch
noch mal richtig nachgelegt das ist
schön vorgestellt wie es war
und dann diese rausgehauen ist doch
nicht also an greetings from germany to
you nächste nachricht kam von keine
ahnung wie das aus wie man wird einfach
geschrieben
21 jahre alt das ist es doch ich finde
es schlimm wenn sowas dann halt oder
wenn jemand so was schreibt und dann so
irgendwie 13 ist oder nicht egal was das
der beste mit 13 habe ich in der schule
fangen gespielt auf dem schulhof aber er
ist auf jeden fall eine bastel alter
okay das ist ja wirklich so also keine
ahnung warum ich das jetzt mit also das
ist ja einfach ich sag mal so ist mehr
teilsweise unfassbar schöne frau finde
ich auch also ich finde du bist wirklich
wirklich wirklich hübsch vorher auch
deine augenbrauen und meine nicht
partnerin brüste also werden von einer
woche oder so ein video gemacht da haben
selbst mit geschrieben dass die maries
augenbrauen und hole mir schon immer so
und dass solche kommentare an hier gehen
die das sagen wollte ich nicht weil ich
abrollen stehe also solche kommentare
gehen an mir persönlich vorbei aber ich
finde dass man menschen einfach nicht
noch einmal aus dem bewährten sollte und
nicht so was also würde ich bin nicht
wenn ich unter einem video 100 mal
irgendwas zu augenbrauen leser dann
denke ich mir wirklich was ist mit der
menschheit falsch also reflex da kann
ich nur sagen reflektiert eure eigene
unzufriedenheit nicht auf menschen die
ihr nicht kennt so und mehr kann ich
dazu nicht sagen also denkt vorher nach
bevor er zum schreiben über mich kann
man mittlerweile schreiben was man will
ich bin schon so lange dabei und das
geht wirklich gar nicht mehr an mich ran
aber bei anderen personen ist es
vielleicht noch nicht ganz weg würde dir
1000 euro überweisen wenn du mir deine
telefonnummer gibt wirklich keinen spaß
kann auch erst überweisen
1000 euro
das aufschreiben doch mal dass das noch
mal gerne ihre kontoverbindung und dann
gibt es eben halt einfach seine
telefonnummer und dann legst du dir für
15 euro einmal wieder eine neue
telefonnummer 89 euro gewinnen einfacher
gehts doch nicht nur leicht für dieses
geld also bei so einem angebot da würde
ich ja nicht zweimal überlegen kann also
man muss ich auch sagen du hast auch ein
paar internationale anscheinend dabei
also hab ich ja sehr sehr wenig
natürlich manchmal kriege auch nachricht
von spanien und von japanern und von
russen aber ganz ganz wenig früher war
das meer und zwar hat antonia
schriebe hallo hallo schöne und er hat
so ein bild so das könnte auch so weiter
so ein typisches erwachsenen self was
sagst du dazu wenn er sowas rüstung
sondern oder freust du dich darüber oder
reich an einem wartburg ua punkt es gibt
knapp oder sagen wir punkten wollen
kennt ihr körper schreibt mal zurück
oder klappt und was kommt und malkursen
bild hiervon quartal alle die quappe
kennen jetzt mal nen dicken doch noch um
hier bei mir bitte an mag
du kennst dich krakow das war ja
wirklich eines meiner lieblings pokémon
also seine akteure war echt nett hier
kann man das ist klar du bist mal wieder
dran mit vorlesen
hey ich muss dich was fragen sollte
sachen stellt sagen die nur damit man
antwortet weil er wird man automatisch
neugierig ich habe schon so oft auf
sowas geantwortet nicht mehr befreien
dann kommt halt immer nur so ja wie alt
bist du oder sowas ja aber das ist
schlau von mir
das von asche
[Musik]
jaja so das nächste da dachte ich
mehrheit so wirklich hey das ist ja
ähnlich wie dieses mit dem 1000 euro
direkt überweisen
ja das ist ich weiß keine ahnung haye
hat eventuell bogdan geld aufzubessern
keine sorge ist nichts schlimmes oder
illegales in klammern denkt man ja
besonders im internet gibt bescheid
falls sie interesse hast dann kann ich
dir mehr dazu sagen
peace out zahlung voraus ich habe also
jetzt mal man muss ja nicht immer direkt
vom schlimmsten ausgehen meister ist
könnte ja auch sein dass er zum beispiel
modelagentur hat und dir für den job
1000 euro gehen würde kann man ja nicht
wissen ja es könnte auch etwas anderes
sein so klar ja ich geh halt auch so was
einfach prinzipiell nicht einfach und
ich denke man kann auch über andere
sachen und geld verdienen aber auch dass
nicht über solche nein man kann auf
klassischem wege geld verdienen man
braucht nicht sowas und so mein job ist
ja so klassischerweise youtuber ist ein
klassischer so also an jack da musst du
dir für das nicht mal was besseres
überlegen also das kommt wirklich du
musst dann auch direkt mit der tür ins
haus fallen das ist ganz wichtig damit
die leute direkt wissen worum es geht
und ich nicht als perversen 50-jährigen
einstufen der da hinter seinem fake
account sitzt so warte mal was haben wir
denn noch
ja gut nicht von dieser welt wunderschön
nahezu perfekt 100 prozent oder solid
oder aber wenn er das bild und weißt du
ja das ist schon immer so diese
doppeldeutigkeit das ist halt so ein
model bild von marie also von diesem
genau genau so das ist halt so da kann
ich mich richtig
also das kann man so als junge glaube
ich viel besser nachvollziehen meister
sowie man dann halt als junge denken
oder wie er denkt und warum er halt so
ein bild so weit würde ich
wahrscheinlich auch machen dann muss ich
auch nicht haben wir das schon gehabt
vom dr professor nicht der typ der sich
dr professor und sagt marie kannst du
mir ein bild von dir schicken bitte
[Musik]
und das ist auch so richtig dummen
solche nachrichten kriege ich auch
manchmal also auch manchmal so von von
mädels jetzt früher mehr als heute
warum weiß ich eigentlich gar nicht
warum ist das so und und das kann ich
meinen instanz nicht hat ja genau das
kann ich verstehen weil guckt doch
einfach ich habe so viele fotos da kann
sie alle angucken wenn die die haben ein
handy das so haben 90 einfach switcher
hin zu schneiden wahrscheinlich sind das
so leute die wollen dann ein bild was es
nicht gibt kann ich mir vorstellen aber
gut man kann es nicht genau wissen heute
dass man als insgesamt zehn nachrichten
ich würde sagen die waren ganz
unterhaltsam also schöne grüße an alle
notfälle menschen da draußen und soll
ich das nicht sagen
abonniert meinen youtube kanal auf jeden
fall und wir sehen uns gerne auf
instagram unsere kanäle ab und stellt
euch doch mal vor wieder ran
dann habe ich mal wieder handvoll monate
hätten gerne alle leute ach so sollte
ich vielleicht ein motto zu sagen dass
nicht alles nachrichten wesentlich nicht
beantwortet habe
einfach weil die alle in so eine schiene
gehen dass wir die in so einem video
zeigen würden ich werde keine
nachrichten wie ich sonst so von euch
bekommen oder so zeigen deswegen
schreibt mir gar nicht an bord auch
recht also leute haut rein